hey dr. only up almost here dears we got
to go quick yes we call a month ago with
my friend that has was is on dialysis
and she has lupus or try to high blood
pressure and low platelets but she's
doing much much better the only thing
that she still has her high blood
pressure and what is she way what is she
way she's 125 and she's crying for
okay now let's stop there for a second
if you see if she's seeing progress with
her lupus and they're telling her her
blood work is good there we may be able
to reduce her dialysis we maybe even get
her off of it at this point he's not
unusually giftables down all the time
over the habit pressure and 125 pounds I
would definitely get her two bottles a
month of the ultimate daily classic
tablets oh look at the daily classic
tablets you know make sure she's taking
three of those twice a day or two three
times a day for a total of six a day and
it's imperative drop dead everybody in
the household he's got to be free of
gluten no wheat no barley rye oats
everybody's got to be free of the fried
foods the processed meats the oils and
again the gluten wheat bun around oats
and the fact that she's shown
improvement on something shows she is
absorbing some okay so it's a good thing
of course the lupus is imperative she
says we're away from all the purine
containing foods which is shellfish the
games like peas beans lentils and
peanuts and also Argan these brain heart
liver kidneys all those got to go and
she can use the what you give her for
pain in her joint Charmaine I give her
the Sam cream and then put some trauma
oil in it you get an A+ here yep give
her the same creamy char says a great
topical pain reliever and get a couple
of those little 10 ml bottles of the
trauma oil from our ancient legacy
division aromatherapy oil division put
five drops to the trauma oil each
teaspoon of the same cream mix it up
real good and apply that to her thumb
for big toe her neck hips knees wherever
she's got the gout eat problems
then ten minutes or so is you need to
get a significant or total pain relief
for about three to five hours she cleans
up the diet take some 90s sense of
nutrients in her case because the liver
needs to go to work here I'd get her to
I get a one healthy brain and hard pack
would also throw in another bottle same
so you can take six of those a day and
we'll walk you ladies through this